a lot of people just cut here
and they've got you here and then they
do this
what i want to do is to make this uh
beautiful aikido
work from
my big toe
to my little finger you know right to
the tips of my body
as it comes as i tell my
my foot to go in my hand turns
but it has him now here
not firmly but but that was because my
my foot turned without without
that's why terry dobson said i
like dancing because it is
it's got to be all connected if you're
not connected you can't have mass
without mass you're another's person's
equal
[Music]
i need that because i perhaps don't want
him to come around any further
this is the full stop that i've put on
well you don't need to because look
that's where
where they should be falling
the reason they get out of the hip is
because it looks great for the demo it
looks and it's good for the uk
and you then all you do is step through
but a lot of people can't take the
highfall so
but this is what i'd like you to do see
this hand here
because i can decide whether i close it
or leave it open
that's exactly tea form as
[Music]
could get me in the ribs
so that's why
the blending is so
important
can you do anything
um
okay